okay so I have like about an hour and a
half of material here I was planning a
40-minute talk I discovered with 30
minutes slightly late in the day I'll
see what I can do
although I would appreciate it if people
feel like interrupting and asking
questions feel free and if I don't cover
anything that I mentioned in the
abstract absolutely feel free to catch
up on me with me later and ask me okay
the purpose of this talk is to describe
basically practical project experience
with the sort of difficult challenge
that we might encounter at work
this is a specific problem we got about
a year ago and I'm just going to tell
you how we approached the problem and
the sorts of things that we did to deal
with it I will say specific so what's
important is that our our our approach
to these problems is defined very much
by a probabilistic programming approach
which we use for dealing with these
sorts of small data problems and I was
delighted to see that the Stan logo
appeared up on the screen in the
introductory talk because our primary
tool for these things is Stan which you
can use through hi Stan and because you
can use it through PI Stan I'm standing
here fundamentally but really this is
principally a talk about Stan okay and
the methods around that so in our line
I'll talk I'll tell you about the
challenge look at the data understanding
the data modeling the data and
extrapolating the data by which time it
will be about a quarter past one okay so
this is the problem about a year ago a
large pharma company contacted us and
asked us basically to build a model that
would extrapolate out for the next nine
months the sales of three different
products in a variety of regions okay
the time series I'll show you them in a
second is short so everybody talks about
Big Data my daily bread and butter work
consists of exceedingly small data this
data came on one Excel spreadsheet and
it was a small Excel spreadsheet okay
there are other points there that I will
mention as I go through we use two basic
tools to let you know up up front we
start off by using a Gaussian process
and then we move on to using a custom
States based model both of which we
solve using Stan
and those prop the fact that we solved
and Stan has specific properties which
are important okay so here's the data
this is the complete data we got this up
to but it's been a bit normalized so you
can't actually see what the actual
values are but what you can see is that
there are three different products in a
variety of different markets so you've
got brown one
you've got brand - you've got brown 3 a
Sun extra complexity apart for the fact
that you've only got but 70 data points
that most is that you will see that
later on in the game the company
introduced a new package of these
products for these products so I forget
what happened actually in one particular
case but I believe if I remember
correctly this used to be sold as a file
and then they discovered that doctors
were opening the file and using it twice
and really to discourage that they
started distributing it as a prepackaged
syringe so you couldn't use the same
thing for for two things okay so what is
interesting here is not actually the set
the challenge that extra bit of the
challenge which I won't really get to
today except maybe if I have a little
bit of time at the end is that you're
interested in the underlying trend
you're not interested in these specific
lines you're interested in the car
the nation of the two okay so you see
that for brown one you've got two trends
for brand - you've got two trends and
for round three you only got one trend
to make things a little simpler it turns
out to be a good guy good bet a good
choice we focus on brown water on brand
three that is what we did at the
beginning you know you you you picked
the easy thing it turned out to be a
serendipitous choice because if we'd
been busy trying to figure out what
exactly was going on in these more
complicated cases we would never manage
to figure out anything at all and it
turns out in the end they're actually
these more complicated cases don't make
things any more complicated okay
so this is the data we've got what's the
first thing you do you know you get you
get the data from the client you open up
open up your system you have these time
syriza's okay the first thing you do the
econometrics tool of choice is you run a
lowest regression through it okay know
what's important in this case well there
many important things in this case are
that this is a completely standard the
idea at this point is not to choose
anything okay you want to use things
straight out of the box making no
assumptions that if possible you are
trying to figure out what exactly is
going on here okay and this is the first
thing you do so you draw their lowest
regressions and you get these things
this doesn't actually tell you very much
unfortunately
Lois is kind of a primitive primitive
gadget but it's it's it takes ten
minutes to run it so you run it okay
well you can see now that I've joined
the dots together and stuff is it things
start off small and then the noise gets
bigger okay as we go along which is not
really surprising you know down here
they're probably selling ten units
they've introduced it into the market
and then as they sell more and more
stuff then it the noise from month to
month
yes that's greater okay so Louis is is
kind of the baseline standard but we can
do a lot better than that okay so what
we're going to do is we're going to
build the first thing we do is we build
a Gaussian process are people familiar
with Gaussian processes here yeah okay
so those that are not a Gaussian process
is a bit like a neural net only for very
small data with much much better
mathematical foundations what that
sounded like a smartass remark I'll
actually explain to you what they what
the value of the extra foundations is in
a second okay
what is important here is there a lot
there are several talks in this
conference on Gaussian processes I don't
know what they're going to say but
unusually with respect to standard
practice since we build our Gaussian
process in Stan we extract the marginal
not the maximum likelihood and we can
also put in a custom noise model okay so
there's lots of stuff to talk about here
so let me talk about it okay here is a
Gaussian process programmed in stamp
complete okay I don't really expect you
to understand this off the fly but what
is going on here is we are essentially
trying so there lots so what we what we
can see we look at the data and we can
see the first question we have to ask
ourselves is what is the nature of this
annoys so we've got the Gaussian
processes that is going to attempt to
draw a line like the Lois but it's going
it's a much more ambitious attempt to
draw a line but on top of the line we
have a noise process which we have to
model separately because we're doing
this in Stan in a probabilistic
programming language we can do lots of
interesting things that we can't do with
an awful officer off the packet off the
peg package for instance the first thing
we decided was this noise is growing
bigger over time yeah so this is a
single
nice process its ourself with small
noise and it gets bigger noise grows we
are going to assume because it's a
reasonable thing as the square root of
the amplitude of the under the
underlying process makes sense yeah I
mean down here you buy you're buying one
product up here you're buying ten
products the variance will go up the
variance will go up with the scale
that's the the standard deviation will
go up with the square root okay the
other at least nice thing one thing we
didn't do here is one thing that we
often have to consider is we use non
Gaussian noise okay but in this case we
didn't use non Gaussian noise because
what we're obviously getting is not or
it's plausible to think that we are
getting noise from a binomial
distribution so two good approximation
its Gaussian what else is there to say
yeah what would it be nice and what we
experimented with was you could make
this line the amplitude of the function
itself actually drive the noise process
so you could say depending on where you
are on the vertical axis that
automatically defines the noise process
this will be the ideal and you can write
down a model that will actually do this
well you can if you make a couple of
other modifications as well but it turns
out that that doesn't work even though
not the nice thirties so what we
actually did was rather than half the
principal so here you hear you have an a
principled unprincipled compromise made
for the purposes of actually getting
things to work rather than take the
noise driven off the underlying process
we looked at the actual samples and took
the the moving average in to find and
use that to define the scale of the
noise process okay the other thing we
did is if you use a Gaussian process you
know even though even an off the peg one
one of the problems is there are a
couple of free variables that you have
to calibrate yeah yes
yeah exactly
I come to that later we're not even
close to the extrapolation bit yet yes
my question is basically when a Gaussian
process extrapolates into this space
where it has no data points it reverts
to the mean indeed you're you're
anticipating my thoughts okay thank you
okay
[Music]
anyway the point the an important point
is that because we're taking the
marginal value we can also marginalize
over prior distributions on the the
three parameters in the model so as I
said we using the lowest model we use a
parameter less model and in this case
even though we built the model ourselves
we're fundamentally using a parameter
Atlas model we're not trying to guess a
particular value so that we can
calculate the maximum likelihood value
we're taking the the marginal okay which
is what this thing does
okay we run the Gaussian process over
the data and this is what we get this is
very interesting for starters you can
see the Vikas Ian process is finding a
lot more structure in the data than the
lowest regression could you can also see
and this is what I meant about the extra
mathematical structure that because
we're taking the marginal distribution
over the underlying process we can take
we have credible in we can calculate
credible intervals for the Gaussian
process okay so the blue line is the
actual thing is the actual fit the
marginal and the red lines show the one
standard deviation variance in the
underlying set and of course you can
also see that of course the variance
goes up as you get up because the noise
goes up yeah so that the fit gets
fuzzier okay so this is what we get as I
said we see immediately more structure
one of the interesting things is again
this is an actual you know actual work
in progress a project with actual
consultants in the room it's not an
academic exercise so at this point all I
had was this but I did notice things
like this
okay what does this mean and you can see
that that you can see similar structure
in many of the various and many of these
okay so simply eyeballing it it suggests
that something is going on here that we
don't know and you put this up in the
room with the the marketing experts on
the product and they say ah of course
this is where a competitor introduced
another product okay so what you're
looking at here is a secular event this
is this is nice because it shows that
the the Gaussian process analysis was
able to pick this up reliably on the
other hand it is incredibly bad from the
point of view of attempting to
extrapolate the process because this is
not only a secular event it's a secular
event right at the end of the process
you know strictly speaking at this point
we are hosed we can just go home
unfortunately you can't go home at this
point so what do you do next all right
so what we can see here is a nice a nice
development of sales and you can see
that you know here this is a secular
event we can imagine - something went on
here you can see that the curvatures
here and also that the noise goes up
which is yes all for the same you can
see the same here so what are we gonna
do as somebody already said we cannot
extrapolate with the Gaussian process
okay what we can't use a Gaussian
process for is to figure out what is
going on okay to develop intuitions
because at the beginning of this I
didn't have intuitions about the market
for tainted drugs however on the basis
of what I could see here I could start
to think about a model now this you
cannot extrapolate the Gaussian process
what looks like a Gaussian process but
you can extrapolate it the closest thing
you can get or at least the closest
thing that occurred to us was a
state-space model now a standard Speight
state-space model
is a fairly I mean you can build very
complicated state-space models for the
standards updates based models obviously
won't work in this case what you do then
is you sit around for a week and start
thinking about what exactly happens in
the in the dynamics of drug sales okay
so we're going to assume that you
introduce a product it grows something
happens there's a secular event in the
market which is going to change the the
trend in your sales it will stabilize on
that it will move forward again there
will be another secular shock it will
move forward again so what we had to do
then was to build a model of the
dynamics of a patented product in a
market where competitors were entering
the market at varying times and so after
a couple of experiments what we got was
this okay so this is the set of
equations defining a state-space model
for yep Payton patented drugs but it's
actually pretty pretty general okay what
we have are the observations we've been
under like we've been underlying trend
or we've obviously got observations
which are scaled as before again would
be nice to have the scaling off the
underlying trend but in practice that
doesn't work the models just become
unstable even if you can write down the
equations you've an underlying trend
which has got a drift which is linear
and there's subject itself to a
second-order shift in the drift the
second-order drift has got a mean
regression process so what happens is
basically you are drifting along you
have a particular trend and the trend
itself is being occasionally being hit
hard by something okay with a mean
regression factor which we don't know
the noise here we've just assumed is
Gaussian for reasons explained more
interesting is this thing and again this
is where among many many other reasons
using a probabilistic programming
language like Stan helps you with in
comparison to out-of-the-box standard
models so in this we thought about
things here not because it's because
it's in Stan we need a continuous
distribution okay I originally thought
of using a plus one
process here but a proximal process has
bad properties for current purposes in
the end I used a modified Koshi process
but I had to be quite careful because
interestingly if you if you hit the
thing too hard you know if you have it
you know if you if you move along and
you hit it hard and then you let it
stabilize immediately the model shows
less good convergence properties than it
would otherwise do which is a good
indication that you don't get getting it
quite right okay
so that's what we did and after a couple
of experiments this was the model this
is the complete model again written down
in Stan theoretically you could set well
actually almost all of this you could
theoretically setup in a standard state
space model package looks solving for
maximum likelihood using some sort of a
common filter in practice if you
attempted to solve this model using a
common filter
I am confident you will fail there's
just too much going on you would need to
calibrate it the calibration is too
complicated
etc etc etc so really a model this this
is a purely practical observation I
don't have any theoretical observation
and any theoretical arguments to back
this up but I think it will be very very
hard to get a model like this to solve
it without using a tool like Stan
anyway you set it up and you solve it
and this is what you get okay and you
fit it and again it looks very good
basically the fit looks like what we got
was a Gaussian process okay the
difference again going back to yes is
that we're not in a position because we
have a state-space model to extrapolate
it okay
and we can extrapolate it like that and
that's what we get okay what you can see
is that for this model the confidence
bonds well I should say that
extrapolation in this context is in some
sense trivial because basically it's
just a missing variable problem you just
set up exactly the same model and you
say I don't know the following values
and the model will find them for you
automatically you don't need to do
anything new so you extrapolate it you
can see the confidence bonds widening up
enormous Li but what you can also see is
the extrapolations so this the Green
sorry no not the extrapolations these
are the actual data which we got
afterwards by the way this is a business
this is a pure out-of-sample test the
actual data afterwards is comfortably
for the most part inside the one
confidence interval 1 1 standard
deviation credible interval for the
processes so let's see so this is
actually how we did with respect to the
historical data what you can see as I
said when I was looking at the original
Gaussian process analysis for brown 3
germany basically you're looking at a
secular shock right at the end of the
series so there's no particular reason
why that line should go anywhere it's
worth saying that if you attempt as we
also did that I didn't have a slide to
do it to use a standard ARIMA
extrapolation on the same data
I think this line goes down here now
most of them are the same the the
problem with that shock at the end is
that it completely knocks off any of the
standard
you would use for stationary time series
analysis my big disappointment our big
disappointment was this one as you see
if we'd been allowed to run the line if
we got one more point of data we
wouldn't write down in the middle of the
nine-month trend for the sales in the US
which you missed but other than that we
did pretty well okay so I think I should
probably stop here I prepared an earlier
version of this slide with with with a
draft that said what should I say say
here when I decided not to not to
replace it
because I thought I would just say a few
basic words about the practice of
dealing with problems like this as you
actually confront them we made lots of
we made lots of compromises along the
way what we tried to do was to stick
with what I would call principled
unprincipled design decisions to get
stuff to move forward there was also
lots of stuff that suggested itself that
we didn't really have time to do one of
the things that we wanted to do early on
and didn't have time but would have done
if we'd had an extra four weeks is that
you can see and we could see in the
analysis that the for instance Germany
and United Kingdom are many respects
similar and Portugal and Spain have got
our naturally born together there's a
huge great gray market in the products
between Portugal and Spain so one one
market is influencing the other and you
would get more model stability if you
could put those together into one
hierarchical model with everything kind
of you know resting on on each other
separately and unfortunately in the end
we simply didn't have time to build that
hierarchical structure but that would
have been the next step if that time had
been available apart from that it was
just frantic work yeah so I will stop at
that point
thanks a lot brother very interesting
talk very mathematical talk are there
any questions okay thank you very much
for the interesting talk so I have two
questions and the first one is about the
Gaussian process model where you were
fitting maybe if you could show the
slide again sure now that I've got you
want to see the Stan code no no the just
the the fit thing yeah this one this one
okay yeah yeah so I was wondering about
how confident you are about this fit
since around 9.20 it seems like the
noise becomes very wide in comparison to
how much the confidence intervals is
widened so that's a good question I mean
it actually relates also to to work for
these things you know what we had was a
suggestive fit which we used with we
invested a lot of time in building a
model I think we're not building a model
but you know thinking through the
precise dynamics of the mall and in the
end this is what we got I should say
that several models we did to try you
know sketch out a few others and try
them and they simply didn't fit at all I
don't know if you've experienced with
these sorts of Monte Carlo systems but
what happens is you the thing just
doesn't stabilize it does not find its
way to the typical set in technical
terms yeah so you can see to certainty
that so these complicated models if you
can get the model to fit and get good
metrics for performance out of it that's
generally a good indication in my
experience no more than that I can't say
and my second question was about so I
can see it's very hard to fit this very
small data set correct I was wondering
if you were considering data
augmentation to add some extraneous
variables such as economic variables
nope
nope nope correlate with the results
that you see no my experience is that
well for starters I find such activities
unless you're very very careful
methodologically unsigned because you
can't just go fishing through data for
extraneous data we actually got data for
various things as part of the project so
we got things like field sales spend and
stuff and trying to build that into the
model in any way in any way that
acknowledged the structure of the
underlying process to not it impossible
it's extremely hard I mean if you get it
that sort of thing even when it works
mostly works if you've got simple
correlations between external data and
stuff that is not not remotely relevant
in this case I mean I forgot to mention
when I was saying the important court of
work is that in the end a large part of
the data you take is expert knowledge of
the dynamics of the data it's not
actually the numbers you know if you
have if you have a time series of an
that of 70 or 60 points then without
getting information somewhere else
you're just not going to get anywhere
you know so the classical model of
here's a sheet of here's a sheet of
here's a table of numbers sling it over
the set here sing it over the fence and
see what you can do is a complete
non-starter and a project like this no I
mean a large a large part of what you do
is you're trying to figure out from
experts what's actually behind they the
the thing yeah I mean these these are
generative models I think generator
modeling is important let's sort of
thing okay oh there are quite a few more
questions first of all thank you for the
talk just continuing the question I get
it's okay let me okay I can multitask
yeah okay so I mean I think it's not the
proper way just to feed noisy time
series and
for those outliers we see and just to
make a feat which is thought might be
good before that there are some ways to
deal with these outliers for example
weight in E and for shorter time scales
just ever G this is just preparing some
data segmentation so there's only
there's only 70 points in the theories
yeah but for example three points for
example now let's say positive negative
and average one you can just average
sure you could you could do that by
putting an autocorrelation structure
into that will be into the normal smooth
and this was just the first not question
just their comments and for the question
here I see that this is like a feat of
three distributions around minus 50
around the 20 and around 45 for example
with special hate and weeds so I mean
for the next prediction I think this
this can be done based on like assuming
that there are free distributions for
some reason I don't know and there will
be some horizontal shift and also the
hate will be based on those free hates
of free distributions they did you
checked it no I mean part of the point
is that in protests like this I mean a
part of the fact that you're welcome to
try although I think you run the risk of
overfitting with a thing like with a
project like this your front I mean this
is all done to a very short time scale
so what happens is you build something
it works you move on there's always
other models you could try so I cannot
say for other models no they wouldn't
have worked
I mean maybe just only for this models
will work because it's different from
slide 15 I think if you move or here for
example for top right is also free
distributions is seen but for example
for others not but maybe there are
different ways okay
I I'm to be honest I'm I mean just
looking at and saying I see three
distribute
when you're looking at this sort of
small data set is a very dangerous way
to program proceed the the motivate the
the underlying method here is to build a
generative model on the basis of expert
expert understanding of how the market
functions okay so for us an important
insight was where to go was discussing
this with people who understood the the
the sales dynamics of these sorts of
products in the market you know it was
when we think let me saw that I think it
are secular shocks to an all up to to to
a trend in sales yes and then what we
did in this is to fit a model saying
secular shocks to a trend in sales now
and the question then is how sharp the
shots are so in a sense we are already
reflecting the what you just said about
different distributions you know what we
got is straight line band straight line
band and the Janet the general model
fits that from that point of view but
then it's motivated by an underlying
understanding of the dynamics of the
market rather than just bit rather than
just eyeballing the data okay I think we
just have time for a very short question
I'm sorry I'm also gonna hijack the
microphone I'm not one of the organizers
and I would like to encourage you all to
take a look at our hitchhiker guide to
the conference where we discussed the
difference between comments and
questions and windscar encourage you to
his comments rather sorry to ask
questions rather than to make comments
and also of course to approach the
speaker after the talk if you want to
discuss anything further and make all of
your comments and I would like to ask
though you said you were using ten so do
you mean which though inference
algorithm do you mean agency which is
what sorry I didn't understand that so
glad you are using stand stand
rather than common filter for example
and I wanted to understand what do you
mean by Stan as if it's not an infant
it's not an algorithm by a language and
what's kind of stan stan is a
hamiltonian an advance on all Tony in
Monte Carlo simulation system ok yeah
thank you so you can program all these
things in Stan it's a general general
tool for building
I don't really under the
no it's not ok I think the time is over
their eyes can see there are more
questions feel free to ask me just come
to the speaker and let's thank the
speaker left again thanks a lot